mein name ist luca herzlich willkommen
wir heute zu einem video auf einem kanal
dass ich so noch nicht gemacht habe und
auch dass ich sehr bock habe und zwar
spiele ich heute sketch bull puncto mit
der lupe und zwar seht ihr hier schon
dass ich ein custom rom erstellt habe wo
acht leute aus euro von euch die chance
hatten mit rein zu kommen ich habe das
auf instagram gepostet den link an und
ich würde sagen es gibt direkt los und
ich muss direkt an bord zeichnen to the
world to draw gips ohrring oder barcode
habe ich mit dem bergholz dem barcode zu
zeichnen ist halt extrem i wie man macht
einfach so zeichnet hier so ein paar
verschiedene 901 also denn das kann man
doch erkennen klavier hat gemäss lilly
hat sgs wo ist denn das im bau matti als
also ich kann das den leuten ja nochmal
einkreisen das ist halt um das hier geht
also das ist mich ein teil von irgendwas
sondern es geht halt um dieses vor hat
aber das ist jetzt vorbei
es haben es haben nur drei die nun zwei
leute haben es erraten selbst mag jetzt
ein wort das heißt ich kann jetzt im
chat mit raten er weist glaube ich nicht
wie man malt
celle
[Musik]
malst du da hier oben seht ihr das wort
eingeblendet und er hat alles gelöscht
es sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein
schneemann aber das kann nicht passen
[Musik]
was soll das ich habe absolut keinen
plan was das sein soll
irgendwas mit ära zu beginnen aber das
steht halt nichts er malt halten
komplett beschützen
künftig ist jetzt dran mit dem zeichnen
also ich hoffe dass sie es besser macht
m ist es ein ufo das ist das ist ein
schnuller oder nils es in pilsen
das ist ein sombrero oder so nemec
mexikaner ich bin so stark ist
sie kann als klaus mexiko war die
einzige person die mit spiel vielleicht
hätte ich es nicht direkt starten soll
mit den ersten acht leuten die geträumt
film zugang muss jetzt ein wort malen
es sieht es ist eine straße das sieht
sehr aus wie eine straßenbahn waren
gleich autobahn etwas mit waren
bahnschiene bahnschienen schienen
schienen ist groß china chinas klaus
hermann allee der ski den schienen es
doch richtig hugh grant ex kreml musste
zeichnen ich glaube der war vorhin schon
ab k
es war
matthias muss jetzt zeichnen und das
wort hat nur vier buchstaben
es ist das sieht aus wie eine blume oder
essen ist es soll das ein pilz hat die
schreib einfach mal pilz reimer hat ja
nicht blume
wo
am ende blume woher haben die alle das
wort hose achso all das ist doch keine
rose die gabe rose sieht so aus aber
nicht so bruder einfach ich hasse euch
willi muss jetzt ein wort zeichnen und
das wort hat sieben buchstaben ich weiß
nicht was das sein könnte vielleicht
löffel was sieht denn das aus sieht auch
aus wie ein schnuller gitarre gitarre
violine die zweite runde startet nun
allerdings meine lieben freunde ich kann
mich entscheiden zwischen tumor
mayonnaise und aufkleber ich nehme
einfach mal in mayonnaise das sollte ja
nicht so schwer sein
ich starte einfach mal so so sieht er
aus wie ein pinsel wisse ja dass hier
drin weil ich jetzt einfach mal gelb das
hier vorne mache ich mal im sommer ton
und dann mache ich hier und noch einen
kleinen mayonnaise flecken lichtschwert
alles klar matthias wahrscheinlich ist
das nicht schwer zugang
ich klicke jetzt einfach mal die leute
raus die hier bisher nichts gerissen
haben sie auch mal raus soll sind direkt
neue leute rein geträumt vielleicht geht
er jetzt ein bisschen spannender musik
malt auf jeden fall ein fort es sieht
aus wie eine ente okay ist nicht vogel
allgemein mehr sparen
es hat ein das ist das ist ein
das ist ein truthahn
das ist ein guter händler bruder albert
hirt wussten dass ein adler drei wochen
später papagei matthias daran mit malen
das sieht aus wie ein strichmännchen
mann/frau matthias lösch alles wieder
wir haben als dritten buchstaben ein
eher kopf kann es ja auch nicht sein
brille geht auch nicht rd am ende bin
ich so blöd
ja ich habe absolut gar kein plan
ich habe gar kein ich kenne das wort
nicht nur als nächstes ins lager hier
dran mit malen
das sieht gar nicht mal so beschissen
aus und ich könnte das ist ein strauß
was schreiben die da denn geld sie
truthahn ente vogel ganz giraffe
wahrscheinlich ist die havel matthias
was ist er schreibt was jet jetski ja
leute dass er nicht cool wenn ihr das
war ein schreibt er das ist ja das ist
ja nicht der sinn vom spiel dauert jetzt
auf jeden fall dass worten das wort hat
wieder nur ich hab es ist der mond das 5
ich bin wieder dran mit zeichnen und
kann mich entscheiden zwischen comet
libel oder hercules das sind alles drei
richtig bescheuerte wörter ich nehme die
pelle
ich habe allerdings überhaupt keine
ahnung wie eine libelle so genau
aussieht ich glaube irgendwie so zwei
augen mund weil sich das an das zeichnen
soll als auch noch erhalten aber eher
wie soll man denn eine libelle zeichnen
luca fügt mal im schnitt bitte hier
jetzt ein bild von einer libelle 1
gutmann
christie's zeichnet jetzt auf jeden fall
die könnte mir auch noch gefährlich
werden für den ersten platz im dies
gerade dritte das sieht aus wie eine
kerze oder irgendwie sowas nee ich
schreib einfach mal kerzenlicht bei
kerzen könnte zu kurz sein
[Musik]
mit s und mit gi lippenstift nein nein
ich war nur dritte aber ob darüber
matthias aber finde ich geil
mittlerweile ist jeder wirklich mit
dabei keiner ist irgendwie afk ich
wusste halt zu beginn noch nicht dass
sich leute einfach während des spiels
auch raus kicken kann und mir macht das
wirklich extrem viel spaß also wenn ich
sowas öfter machen soll dann lasst auf
jeden fall jetzt schon leid da unter dem
weg was ist das das ist doch jetzt mein
schnuller oder nicht das ist in
suppenlöffel das ist nötig ist glos
warte löffel seet de
also ich kriege noch ein herzinfarkt ich
hab ja vor ein paar wochen schon mal
skripal punkt mit max und seppel auf
einem kanal gespült
das kam auch mega gut bei euch an
allerdings bei sketch punkte eu halten
möglich dass man dass ich euch einfach
den link post auf instagram also ich
hasse laser luca so folgt mehr da weil
dort werde ich die links dann in zukunft
immer posten samawi
die auch bruder schreibt das doch nicht
hin was das ist ich finde es vor allem
von eis wie ähnlich meinen charakter
einfach meinem youtube logo aus sieht
sich aber gut weg to business ready
parkett zeichnen wieder das wort einfach
rein geschrieben das war nicht so cool
aber dass ihr könnt ihr interessant
wären das sieht auch das ist ein das ist
ein volleyball das ist ein volleyball
das ist ein polyp weil ich war
1830 habe ich das römische volleyball
turnier gewonnen matthias schreibt
einfach nur her in den weg kommt gar
nicht klar matthias einfach fünfter ich
würde gern so eine best-of matthias
zusammenstellung von diesem video haben
was da für eine scheiße geraten hat das
hier ist jetzt auch schon das letzte
bild das heutige video gezeichnet wurde
und zwar hat so jeder es gezeigt
beziehungsweise zeit die spinne das ist
doch eine spinne
das ist so eine spinne mit b
was ist eine sonne
das ist saßen drache le matin schreibt
spinnennetz krabbe eine krabbe fliegt
noch nicht und dann wasser das spiel das
auf jeden fall vorbei meine lieben
freunde ich habe es selbstverständlich
den ersten platz belegt glückwünsche
gehen auf jeden fall auch raus anuga und
kristic die hier den zweiten und dritten
platz belegt haben matthias schreibt
luca kommt das im video ja matthias du
bist definitiv im video und wenn euch
das heutige video hier gefallen hat dann
das gern einen daumen hoch unter dem
video hier da schreibt mir gerne und in
die kommentare ob ich das öfter
hochladen soll und abonniert main kanal
falls es eine wöchentliche serie
eventuell werden soll so immer einmal
wöchentlich sketch folio luca mal mit
der lupe
[Musik]